[Applaudissements]
allez
on se fait des bisous
moi aussi je t'aime salut
[Applaudissements]
et on souffle les bougies
et je vous le dis et je le redis ce sont
ces gens-là qui envoie la France dans le
mur je vous le dis si on est dans une
situation comme ça aujourd'hui ils sont
très très ils ont une très grande part
de responsabilité sachez-le et je pense
qu'on fait beaucoup plus pour la France
bien sûr que tous ces
grades papier qui ne font que mettre de
l'huile sur le feu sacré numéro
ils doivent ah oui mais eux ils sont
dans l'action 65 ils sont contents ils
font leur petite chronique ils font rire
trois personnes trois bobos qui sont
contents avec leurs mocassins Minelli et
ils vont arrêter de nous faire chier non
mais je vous le dis ouais
bon qui vous voulez le numéro de qui
parlons peu parlons bien vous êtes fans
monsieur Macron par rapport
si au contraire je réussis moi le joueur
qui à qui toujours à réussir qu'il y ait
été réélu etc j'arrive à le faire passer
par un vote normal fuse de trois ou cinq
voies donc votre analyse l'après-midi
je pense qu'ils ne veulent absolument
pas du 49-3 parce qu'en effet c'est pas
flamboyant comme sorti alors on peut
appeler l'Elysée
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous lui demanderiez alors
non rien rien pour l'instant d'accord
toujours pas de fumer blanche ici à
l'Élysée toujours pas de fumée blanche
il va falloir prendre une décision pas
de fumée blanche et une fumée blanche
mais fausse alerte c'était juste
Elisabeth borne qui qui vapoter dans son
bureau
à l'instant BFM TV annonce que l'option
du 49-3 vient d'être validé donc ce sera
à 49-3 selon BFM TV
c'est quand même exactement la même
chose là ce sera un 49,3 et là c'est
quand même une révolution qui se qui se
prépare
[Applaudissements]
ocratie rassembler s'il vous plaît sinon
je le suce pour la séance
sous les hués Elisabeth borne se dirige
vers la tribu debout les élus insoumis
brandissent des pancartes 64 ans c'est
non et antonne-la marseillaise
une bonne pensée de Confucius une petite
impatience ruine un grand projet c'est
bien juste ça visage grave des ministres
le garde des sceaux réconforte Olivier
du soft qui a porté la réforme
finalement elle n'est pas soumise au
vote sur le fondement de l'article de 49
la responsabilité de mon gouvernement la
démocratie
[Applaudissements]
est éliminatoire voilà notre rêve il est
complètement
brisé chez un atout donné franchement la
défaite elle est elle est immense passée
en force et un signe qu'ils enfoncent le
pays tout entier dans une crise de
régime et à ceux qui au pouvoir
aujourd'hui s'aiment le chaos dans ce
pays nous répondrons évidemment par la
censure il faut censurer ce gouvernement
donc non seulement nous déposerons une
motion de censure mais nous voterons
l'ensemble des motions de censure qui
vont être déposés voilà annoncé
elle-même qu'elle accepté d'être le
fusible banco qu'elle saute Etienne
ah on lâche rien
[Applaudissements]
depuis le début de la mandature c'est
quand même un site c'est quand même un
problème en démocratie Emmanuel Macron
avait répété qu'il souhaitait à vote
mais le 49-3 s'impose à lui
à 14h40 il se justifie devant le Conseil
des ministres
les risques financiers économiques sont
trop grands il y aura un vote sur le
texte c'est la motion de censure on ne
peut pas jouer avec l'avenir du pays
qui ne lâche pas
entêté c'est bon vous découvrez sur sur
ces images en direct la voiture
d'Elisabeth borne la première ministre
qui a donc quitté qui va se diriger vers
l'assemblée c'est pas très loin il y a
la scène à traverser des dizaines de
rassemblements d'opposants à la réforme
des retraites tous déplore la méthode du
gouvernement
il est tout seul
on a un 49-3 c'est vrai que c'est c'est
vraiment du mépris de la violence c'est
voilà je lis il y a de la il y a du
malaise et de la colère mais je me dis
Nathalie zen ferme ta grande gamelle
porte ta brouette de travers et avance
[Musique]
est-ce que c'était bien le moment est-ce
que c'était bien le moment de
d'imposer une réforme génératrice
d'angoisse dans un moment
où les gens ont vu ce succéder beaucoup
d'angoisse le covid la guerre en Ukraine
l'inflation la peur du lendemain
donc après les gens ils me font rire
ma vie mais ça ne connaît
à la pêche à la chasse à quoi non mais à
un moment donné il sait bien le travail
qui valorise à l'homme non est-ce qu'il
y avait pas moyen peut-être de retarder
peut-être de se rasseoir de rediscuter
d'essayer de s'interroger sur ce qui
préoccupe autant les gens depuis depuis
quelques mois depuis quelques semaines
tous ces gens qui sont dans la rue tous
ces gens qui qui ont
un sentiment de de voilà de de pas être
entendu donc pourquoi ne pas se rasoir
est-ce qu'on était à 6 mois après est-ce
qu'il y avait pas moyen de renouer et de
renouer le dialogue moi je ne crois
qu'au dialogue